[Musique]
j'suis à lt img la reine esclaves dans
une usine sans chauffage ou ans et gel à
porter ce costume éclaté en plus c'est
du taillan fange et dont la pierre
beebeejaun leur rentrer dedans cher
petit papa espèce de gros [ __ ] tu vas
bien démerdé bon look à la soirée 400
ans qu'on est en stage non rémunéré
teysseyré pas nous la mettre ta grosse
bûche dans la cheminée alors on parle
des conditions de travail nous on bosse
toute l'année toi juste s'asseoir
est ce normal exploitez 20 heures par
jour en échange pas insensible salle de
la douane et de la purée la cantine des
blacks ça l'instant l'atelier s'est mis
du harcèlement mais ça fait mal tiré sur
la victime en coloc hashtag ne résout
pour que la vérité exploseront va faire
cracher lozère à ce bâtard de santa
claus sympa d'irlande gros lot groleau
savait pas de cadeau mado et même si tu
as été sage été comme hiver les lutins
verts ebener von ah mais
sapins guirlandes groleau gros lot ça
n'est pas de cadeau cadeaux et même si
tu as été sage été comme hiver les
lutins verts et vénère ben thamer
groënland c'est le dr terre qu il est le
père père noël cette année ça sent la
poudre et là qu'est la maltraitance
animale mon gars
fallait pas que [ __ ] le code du
travail sur le régime libyen a juré
parfois des syndiqués devraient faire la
révolution aux foules fut au créneau je
suis déjà au japon gros lot j'ai craché
dans ton et son petit papa ça c'est
cadeau je n'aime pas dire que c'était
mieux avant mais c'était mieux avant
quand on sentait des jouets en bois pour
les enfants maintenant faire un bac
justice pour réussir à tout faire subaru
[Musique]
bernard bonsoir bonsoir je suis le
voisin d'à côté j'attends ce que vous
faites des plus tard et franchement
c'est vraiment pas mal
merci il manque juste un peu plus de
deux mois tu vois un peu plus de 2 c koi
rajoute tout cas tout tout tout tout
bonne soirée à toi je lai châu
j'ai compris et ça fait boum à glace et
hors glace et eau qui bernard vidal
dénombré des minutes
sav
ma glace et au gaz et au liberia où je
suis dingue
ai-je mal géré saab à l'irlande
groleau gros l'eau salée pas de radio
pas d'eau et même si tu as été sage été
comme hiver les lutins verts ebener
votre tamer sapins guirlandes gros lot
groleau ça n'est pas de cadeau cadeaux
et même si tu as été sage été comme
hiver les lutins verts les nerfs ben
thamer
[Musique]